[Music]
[Music]
well guys that's it the 2019 Katowice a
major is at an end and this particular
event had its fair share of goose bump
inducing hair-raising incredible plays
like this one Iko going in first with
the scout counting land some majestic
shot oh and hey that's why we have an
entire video dedicated just to the best
from IEM katowice but that's not why you
clicked on this video is it you came
here for the 10 IQ plays for the cringy
interviewer fails for the easy Firenze
memes or can you actually rate them and
we don't plan on disappointing so let's
get this video started with the best
in-game fails in funny moments from this
past major damage is being inflicted
Nico's lauded a beautiful one top of the
Celsius leading to the one-on-one
Felucia against Niko Niko's trying his
best but Russia holds on for dear life
and cloud 9 will get a third round yeah
that's rough for Nico he you do love to
see that even at a level 90
Wow this is why we like Flushing
even switch alkanes I love everything
about that they've thrown it away now
they're just trying to see if they can
see it over the wall but the idea here
should be at least to see if they can
they can see the echo over the wall
this is ambitious to say the least I
like to see it because I'd like to eat
guns but it doesn't feel like the e key
is actually gonna work for them right
now as they continue to jump and however
in I'm pretty sure everyone watch this
is watching this it's oddly satisfied if
they are able to grab it one last
attempt yeah
northern an ideal situation for me I've
got the bomb he's deciding to fall back
yeah and well automatic völkisch em I
should say being polite close in that
door just toying with Emma slightly back
as a case alright so tries to do
everything he can and they're not
letting him get it killed our teacher
can't make it can't make it no needs to
be thrown it's just gonna be go play oh
oh my god it keeps him safe the bomb
goes down
CT spawn he's gonna move in but now it's
gotta turn back and there's no way from
the stop this defuse this claw this rod
has turned around about six different
times and unfortunately for phase
they're gonna come out on the losing end
flush on the bomb and the defuser is POW
division could kill for a dren novel Oh
No but Ren is a chance flush and
normally so clutch and now add Ren can
get into the site he's sticking it one
more time a dread certainly not he gets
elephant once more dad Ren capitalizes
on the mistakes since you mentioned it
the other members of the team have been
able to lift up their socks they're
doing it again
Jane making sure he hasn't go boil on
his shoes again my goodness made me this
is what struts are for you want to
practice it
oh come on cave not like this brother
especially considering it I don't feel
like there's any flash preceding the
push it was just a Roth long peak when
you have no information can you go find
us to kill now we're now running through
the Malta that's a lot of debt of so
much damage no it's a lot of damage
goodness trying to catch a van Gogh
unawares but they're not gonna be full
at all Fitch and Buster clean house and
it's only shops that can contract with
his Caesar here's like a lot of teams
have had more pressure applied and they
have the opportunity of advancing rather
than
being eliminated that nade slows him
down in the fire oh my god
all right forest is having a barbecue I
can't imagine sharp taste it's nice in
the barbecue though and now's I will in
MBK locked in kitchen and suddenly this
round just feels impossible but never
mind
Zeus what is this a disaster before them
I need to see that again
I cannot comprehend it this roundabout
next there to save the day finding those
two frags
and Epix giving all of the glory through
the hole yes that's that's pretty
accurate mr. garre's I I'd say that
that's a pretty fair assessment as to
what we just witnessed today take him
down it's unlikely they'll recover your
[ __ ] as its Navi not fully investing
they've taken a full eco previously and
not had simple electronic with deagle
armor they - you have a case across the
board here have a fighting chance of
actually doing some witness traps still
a chance to win it with the Eagles armor
etc bats overall phase are being very
comfortable to stay here the D goes far
off as well they know that's just gonna
be pistols against them round 3 and Navi
confirm they don't have rifles at this
point they could fall right back and all
those cross fires we previously
discussed drops immediately at readies
McEntee squad Guardians not sure where
to go
he's won the round he knows exactly
what's happening I rubbed it in his face
big were much better star this time he's
0 for them oh my god Matt have you ever
seen anything like it
he's killed his teammate at the very
start around and they've lost another
kill in the process that couldn't have
actually gone anywhere he was for the
move you to tries Wow
smokes out it's gonna be a dedication to
the a bomb site we go oh dear
and I can hear myself yeah that's kind
of cool well set up for a pretty good
hold here this is an angle and a half
imagine these T's clearing this here
they come into the site zip --ax getting
one anyone above to cake and maybe get a
PT 50 or deagle anyone beneath or at it
and they've stopped each other again I'm
gonna lose my freakin mind
that's Wow for the smoke to dissipate to
get the vision back babysitter on the
ball that's why if you're gonna be there
be dynamic surely if you're gonna
protect the planter at least consider
the options of where the hell are gonna
show up from versus one case they're out
so once again stuck at that door
position and when the time running
loaded towards the peak themselves
facing him make him blog surely there's
10 second remaining that give me an
opportunity to win if they give this
round up it's gonna an absolute disaster
here and pacer otter running out of time
he might actually win this
cloud9 get through by the skin of their
teeth a hollow victory at best what are
they playing at why don't need to beat
him at all ah [ __ ] I can't believe
you've done this knows where he's
planted there's a smoke going down does
he go for the 4d fuse is going for it
now let's fall shy oh no you could see
the disappointment that was his and how
to defend it so therefore they should
know how to attack it though they know
all the tricks on one side and they can
exploit them on the other I guess that's
the whole room all set
it's the kill they're after that mistake
you'll be everything but timing actually
gives it away patient from fugly to help
out gaps in a top spot
Oh on the flip side of that coin that
was not to get a good communication
whatsoever and I mean it just it's it's
so magnificent to see because you don't
need to have some super fancy set piece
or strategy it's just a vice getting an
angle-theta p.m. from that just you do
absolutely blog to see it but it's just
simplicity the magic number is it three
it is three why is it so because the
money's so low right now if only two
players survived they can't drop three
guards please go in Hulk mode and
they've got three he's seeing green down
the bro lab to try and plot this out for
a Swedish brothers up comes Kenny s one
bullet will seal the deal for him he
tries to skip this best simple
impression they won't be working but
there is the man in question Shox if
he's very careful about this oh and if
they're care less about giving him shots
it could end fug Lee's position himself
on heaven strictly so that he can run in
for trade and he's not in an open angle
for him to take advantage of this is
down Stan no question nosey things on
the site boy he's read it so well
fug Lee's go to the office well he can't
find a shot
he liked that shot in return down he
more tilt himself out of heaven I think
he panicked okay he wants both of his
teammates to stay alive he switched to
the off to hit all under his shot and
Shazam beat him to the punch but fugly
solar people Michael himself of Shazam
Capaldi oh my god that was actually hard
to watch I think we should move on to
some of the goofier out of game moments
from Katowice I haven't been the boss
that long
falling he used to be our boss into the
accident the reason we call him fallen
is that one afternoon he fell down with
this 20-foot wave after that I was never
able to carry my t anymore
so at afternoons I'm here mighty fine
trying to find Australia's all trying to
find some Phase II gold but after the X
then I just can't find [ __ ] anymore I
was watching a Diigo tutorial and
apparently if you were tapped to the
song stayin alive okay the hipfire there
the the spread resets during that so if
you get like stayin alive you get
perfect I can't take you seriously I'm
cereal there you go that's the tutorial
I gave you that one for free explain
yeah
so everyone's just kind of got to sit
there and stare at each other awkwardly
what a queuing automatic doing good
we're in some kind of a game both of the
mouse upside down flush is getting
involved now you just know the
conspiracy theories are gone crazy the
tinfoil hats are on
yeah it also means they can be further
away from be potentially every fourth
round so you likewise know you could you
could push something the defensive side
did you're gonna be there the timings
gonna favor you that round and you can
saw the mind games equality be signal
that gotta think we rushed alone at this
point they got a stack three players
there let's just go do be split
straightaway I said stall role for at
times and that others missing an action
he was probably poked you player you got
it a counter-strike and I noticed when I
was playing with them cuz they asked me
and I thought I'd be fun and they only
played the stew and Mirage and I got
thinking about that yeah that makes
sense right they're very similar wraps
their cookie cutter you've got a direct
Wow how lewd no cancer [ __ ] was gonna
be this temperature yeah this call to be
honest you came prepared man look at its
message ready for Eskimos it's all it's
all it's all talk with Jack it's all
targets for you reckon looking like jump
out and land on there and then go back
on what Moses I couldn't let you wear a
tie alone thanks brother I hope that
everyone at home can get a taste of what
it is you have on right now no one wants
to taste that mustache trace it's it's a
nasty one yeah I brought a little bit of
a you know we can't have a major without
enters in some fashion right so we got
to get him involved its gift from my
brother as well my birthday so I gotta
give him a shout-out but this is the
horrible gift this is the face of beauty
this is what a mustache should be we've
already kissed Yeah right now in terms
the oh he's Pleiades connected he's got
a okay he's tilting off the face of the
earth hell that's Wow he's tilting cuz
he's not hopping complexity came into
this vast array of nothing to learn
[Music]
we're here to talk about a cool new
product from turbo called gamer grip you
did some yeah we're back on dolls Jesus
all right cool
okay yes so there was a little bit of a
delay but it appears though we've all
wrangled it in just proper right here at
times tech things happen and to of
course we have address those issues and
we have research focus or I'm in are we
ready yeah oh yes we have gotten this
bad boy back under way and we do have
another best of one coming your way
hello ESL what the [ __ ] is going on with
this electro city do it fast all right
and second thing give me host you got
like 200 viewers 200,000 viewer cost my
channel if not I will come to cut to be
10 o'clock different things okay Roger
the party starts starts ooh gosh yes
therefore my Chanel and will be a lot of
people here a lot good I would say Hugh
is the Z Z he used to be a problem and
now it's not second twice no I mean
never wedding
it's all that matters they are Canadians
I mean it is they are pretty much
existence the second place to the USA
polish boys they did a lot of damage
they got four or five kills between the
two
yeah they got done dirty didn't they
maybe they seemed to be very effective
until you know Oh
oh dear oh no what is Oh J when you need
them
[Applause]
[Music]
we will be coming back with some more
major action tomorrow that is a very
very interesting thing to have happened
in this moment thank you very much for
joining us and let's all put our
lighters up for this moment guys we have
an entire section of this video carved
out just for interview fails and funny
moments and before we get into it I just
want to say being a floor interviewer is
a very difficult job and all it takes is
one research error one last-minute
change and you create an unforgettable
unfortunate interview flub well it's
Terry congratulations on that win now
good luck and we'll see you on the other
side what and do you have any final
words to your coach casados well because
I think he's the most emotional of you
all he's fun a little [ __ ] he's talked
about being the best and they line up
you'll make dance in an Archie didn't
have the best of days now I know that
you never resist the opportunity to send
a message your fellow Canadian and we
got one I love you Deb's well talk to me
about what your team have been up to you
then because we last saw you getting
through to the London major even pushing
forwards fearless the anti-white he'll
go down freeze training but he can't
trade against relics that's it 16 - 5
reunited joy complexity in upsetting
energy in best of threes now we actually
that's so bad in fact you actually had
to fight your way through here and that
is completely my bad because I was at
the Americas miners hosting that desk
and I remember what happened and I
apologize because my bad in every way we
just we don't want us to do
to them the same mistake I don't know
and in terms of now the other teams have
seen you play they can't really be
surprised by you so much anymore but but
do you have any tricks up your sleeve
for this last match yeah we have
subjects inside our pocket so we'll see
we will see indeed we've just been oh I
I think we need to go back to the desk
well actually your mates got some Pete
Sergey to my nickel-sized there we go
I'm just gonna look it's really hungry
work interviewing simple on stage thank
you very much anyway stop right there
criminal scum nobody breaks the law and
my watch I'm confiscating your stolen
goods now pay your fine or it's off to
jail I want us to go through and to go
to to the player that's all my wish
right now so yeah focus on the third map
in I just want to direct this residence
that's this dude's Australian so what
the [ __ ] I'm saying if your wedding in
front of your home crowd I'm kidding
thank you
just kidding and Berlin I have to ask
you you're going to have Rafi T in the
game are you looking forward to playing
CS and seeing your name there are you
are you looking forward to seeing your
naming graffiti you'll get graffiti in
the game yeah I know
I don't speak English so much you know
what Ferlin because this is your home
audience why don't you speak to the
audience and college I am very excited
about this well guys that is all she
wrote for fails and funny moments for
the major now if you're still looking
for the hight plays and the heartwarming
moments we have an entire video just for
those so check that out and I'll see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button